okay so let me ask you about these uh
super intelligent cortical systems that
we engineer and us humans
do you think uh with these entities
operating out there in the world
what does the future most promising
future look like is it
us merging with them
or is it us like how do we keep
us humans around when you have
increasingly intelligent beings is it uh
one of the dreams is to upload our minds
in the digital space
so can we just give our minds
to these uh systems so they can operate
on them
is there some kind of more interesting
merger or is there much more in the
third part of my book i talked about all
these scenarios and let me just walk
through them sure
um the uploading the mind one
yes extremely really difficult to do
like like we have no idea how to do this
even remotely right now um
so it would be a very long way away but
i make the argument you wouldn't like
the result
um and you wouldn't be pleased with
results it's really not what you think
it's going to be
imagine i could upload your brain into
into a computer right now and now the
computer's sitting there going hey i'm
over here
great get rid of that old bio person i
don't need them you're still sitting
here
yeah what are you gonna do no no that's
not me i'm here right yeah are you gonna
feel satisfied in that
then but people imagine look i'm on my
deathbed and i'm about to you know
expire and i push the button and i'm
uploading but think about it a little
differently and
and so i don't think it's going to be a
thing because people by the time we're
able to do this if ever
because you have to replicate the entire
body not just the brain it's
it's really it's i walk through the
issues it's really substantial
um do you have a sense of what makes us
us
is there is there a shortcut to what can
only save a certain part
that makes us truly ours no but i think
that machine would feel like it's you
too
right right you have a few people just
like i have a ton i have a child right i
have two daughters
they're independent people i created
them well partly yeah
and um uh i don't
just because they're somewhat like me i
don't feel i'm them and they don't feel
like on me so if you split apart you
have two people so we can
come back to what what makes what
consciousness do you want we can talk
about that
but we don't have a remote consciousness
i'm not sitting there going oh i'm
conscious of that you know i'm i mean
that
system over there so let's say we let's
let's stay on our topic okay so
one was uploading a brand yep ain't
going to happen in 100 years
maybe a thousand but i don't think
people are going to want to do it
the merging your mind with uh
you know the neural link thing right
like again
really really difficult it's it's one
thing to make progress to control a
prosthetic arm it's another to have like
a billion or
several billion you know things and
understanding what those signals mean
like it's the one thing they're like
okay i can learn to think some patterns
to make something happen
it's quite another thing to have a
system a computer which
actually knows exactly which cells it's
talking to and how it's talking to them
and
interacting in a way like that very very
difficult we're not getting anywhere
closer to that
um interesting can i can ask a question
here
what so for me what makes that merger
very difficult
practically in the next 10 20 50 years
is like literally the biology side of it
which is like
it's just hard to do that kind of
surgery in a safe way
but your intuition is even the machine
learning
part of it where the machine has to
learn what the heck it's talking to
that's even hard i think it's even
harder
and it's not it's it's easy to do when
you're talking about hundreds of signals
it's it's a totally different thing to
say talking about billions of signals
you don't think it's the raw the it's a
machine learning problem you don't think
it could be learned
well i'm just saying no i think you'd
have to have detailed knowledge
you'd have to know exactly what the
types of neurons you're connecting to
i mean in the brain there's these
they're marines that do all different
types of things it's not like a neural
network it's a very complex organism
system up here we talked about the grid
cells or the place cells you know you
have to know what kind of cells you're
talking to and what they're doing and
how their timing works and all
all this stuff which you can't today is
no way of doing that right
but i think it's i think it's a i think
the problem you're right that the
biological
aspect of like who wants to have a
surgery and have this stuff inserted in
your brain
that's a problem but this is when we
solve that problem
i think the the information coding
aspect is much worse i think that's much
more
it's not like what they're doing today
today it's simple machine learning stuff
because you're doing simple things but
if you want to merge your brain like
i'm thinking on the internet i'm merge
my brain with the machine and we're both
doing
i that's a totally different issue
that's interesting i i tend to think if
okay if you have a super clean signal
from a bunch of neurons at the start you
don't know what those neurons are
i think that's much easier than
the getting of the clean signal i think
if you
think about today's machine learning
that's what you would conclude
right i'm thinking about what's going on
in the brain and i don't reach that
conclusion so
sure but i don't think even even then i
think there's kind of a sad
future like you know do i do i have to
like
plug my brain into a computer i'm still
a biological organism i assume i'm still
going to die
so what have i achieved right you know
what have i achieved to do some sort of
oh
i i disagree we don't know what those
are but it seems like there could be a
lot of different applications
it's like virtual reality is to expand
your brain's capability to uh
to to like to read wikipedia yeah but
but fine but but you're still a
biological organization yes yes you know
you're still you're still mortal you're
still all right so
so what are you accomplishing you're
making your life in this short period of
time better right
just like we uh having the internet made
our life better yeah yeah okay
so i i think that's of of if i think
about all the possible gains we can have
here that's
a marginal one it's an individual hey
i'm better
you know i'm smarter um but you know
fine
i'm not against it i just don't think
it's earth-changing i
but but so this is the true of the
internet when each of us individuals are
smarter
we get a chance to then share our
smartness we get smarter and smarter
together as like as a collective this is
kind of like this ant colony
why don't i just create an intelligent
machine that doesn't have any of this
biological nonsense
this is all the same it's it's
everything except
don't burden it with my brain yeah right
it has a brain it is smart it's like my
child but it's much much smarter than me
so i have a choice between doing some
implant doing some hybrid weird you know
biological thing that's bleeding and all
these problems and
limited by my brain or creating a system
which is super smart that i can talk to
um that helps me understand the world
they can read the inter you know read
wikipedia and talk to me
you